[Music]
but I am telling you right now that
mother that that mother back there is
not
real what do you mean I'm not real of
course I'm real I I I I am the President
of the United
[Music]
States all right people it's time for
another Friday Round Table Extravaganza
and joining me today is prageru
personality and host of the wrapup CJ
Pearson and also joining me is columnist
of off limits Ian howth CJ and Ian
welcome to the Reuben report thanks for
having us uh Ian I feel I should start
with you because you've been on once
before and I butchered your name so
horribly I think I called you Ethan
Hawthorne I don't know if I had a stroke
on camera or what exactly happened there
but how'd I do this time I think I
cleaned it up properly yeah you nailed
it that was awesome all right very good
and CJ we we go way back at this point
you're you're with trer you and
obviously I love Dennis and the team
over there but why don't you maybe just
take 20 30 seconds real quick just
introduce everybody uh to yourself and
then we'll dive into all the topics yeah
well Dave thank you so much for having
me it was uh good to be in in in your
city uh a few days ago for the for uh
the presidential debate in Miami and
yeah so I'm here at prageru one of our
Jin Z personalities where we work every
single day to change the hearts and
minds of America's young people and
fight back against a lot of
misinformation I know that you've been
tackling uh you know increasingly you
know in in recent weeks we've just seen
seen just an avalanche of it and so uh
thank you so much for having me yeah
well my pleasure and I'm glad we finally
made it happen and speaking of
misinformation you've given me a very
easy segue to talk about the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC and
their lead Muppet Chris Hayes had Hamas
leader Rashida Talib on the show this is
a day or two and uh well take a look for
yourself resolution also objects to a
passage in a video she released early
this month that calls on President Joe
Biden to support a ceasefire in Gaza
specifically a segment of that video
that depicted protesters in T's home
state of Michigan chanting the phrase
you see there from The River To The Sea
now the resolution called that chant
which is commonly used by some Pro
Palestinian activists quote a genocidal
call to violence to destroy the state of
Israel and its people and to replace it
with a Palestinian State extending from
the Jordan River to the Mediterranean
Sea in a statement congresswoman to
leave rejected that characterization
instead calling it quote an aspirational
call for Freedom human rights and
peaceful coexistence not death
destruction or hate but I do want to
talk about this phrase because obviously
this was a phrase that I think really um
caught some folks I think Jewish
Americans supporters of Israel different
folks and and it reads differently
different people from The River To The
Sea um the contention is that this this
is a call for a kind of anti-colonial
expulsion right similar to like Algeria
kicking out the French right like get
out of here go back to wherever you came
from this is the how it's heard I think
to a lot of Jewish years and so I want
you to explain like what you mean by it
and why you used it or why you include
it in the video yeah I mean look I'm
asking my colleagues don't distort the
words of my residents many people in
this movement for human rights for
Palestinians have always centered it
around coexistence uh you hear them
calling for that uh and saying that you
know no matter your faith your ethnicity
your background you should be able to
live uh without fear without
discrimination without this kind of
inequality that you know netanyahu's
extremist party and his leadership has
been pushing and so for many my
colleagues they know uh and deep in
their hearts where my heart is and many
of the folks including the American
Jewish Community that's out there
demanding again the the call again uh
against this this notion that we can't
all live together okay let let me just
clean up a couple things before I have
you guys jump in first off 100% from the
Jordan River to the Mediterranean Sea
that's where Israel exists when they
talk about it being free they are
talking about getting r of the roughly 8
million Jews and you'd probably have to
get rid of about 2 million Muslim Arabs
who live there and the Christians and
the bah and everybody else so she's just
lying number one uh Hayes by comparing
this to Algeria and the French is
intentionally doing something deeply
dishonest which is that the French are
not indigenous to Algeria the Jews are
indigenous to Israel that's number two
uh and finally when she says that many
Palestinians have called for coexistence
please show me any Palestinian anywhere
any March anywhere show me the name of
Palestinian peace movements uh show me
the the deals that pal the Palestinians
have put on the table that have been for
two states or any of those things
they've repeatedly rejected them etc etc
now that I'm out of breath Ian take it
away unbelievable I mean she's just
lying it it's the honestly the most
Shameless lie I've ever seen on
television and that's saying something
in the state of our political system
right now from The River To The Sea
means the mass expulsion or mass murder
of every Jew and Christian by the way uh
in what they want to call Palestine
it's what it's always meant when they've
said it's going to be an Arab state from
the water to the water prior to the
existence of the modern state of Israel
and she talks about peace and
coexistence and love how much peace and
coexistence and love is in Gaza or the
West Bank or Syria or Lebanon why are
there no Jews in really any Muslim State
across the world it's because they get
persecuted they get pushed out and they
get murdered and that's exactly what
she's calling for it's what people she's
defending are openly calling for you
can't say they want coexistence when
they're chanting things like f the Jews
Gass the Jews kill the Jews calling for
violence not just subtly overtly calling
for violence it's a Shameless lie I
think it says everything we need to know
about MSNBC that they're really
providing cover for her yeah and by the
way to reiterate I have no problem
calling her a Hamas supporter that is my
right as a free American as long as I
have it and since she refuses she's been
uh questioned in the halls of Congress
repeatedly to condemn Hamas and that's
it why she's an American congresswoman
why hasn't she demanded the release of
the 12 American hostages unconditionally
uh CJ as a as a gen Zer uh unfortunately
what we're seeing is a generation at
least a generation that has been just
completely brainwashed on this stuff and
everything else what do we do about that
you know it's been shameful to see what
we've been you know looking on our
college campuses recently but I can't
say that I'm surprised you know we've
seen for many many years so many folks
in Academia grooming America's young
people to hate America so why wouldn't
they hate Israel too why wouldn't they
hate the only democracy in the Middle
East that is tolerant um that shares our
ideals shares our value shares our
appreciation for Freedom there's a
reason there our strongest I li there
and and it is for good reason and so I
think that at the end of the day we have
to reach young people where they are
with truth and with facts and I know
that you guys were you know talking
about you know rashita Tes as blatant
lies but I think it's a little bit more
offensive because she's gaslighting
people with a straight face and I find
that particularly offensive to sit there
and try to redefine what from The River
To The Sea means as if we don't and have
never seen a map is just blatantly
offensive and it's wrong and I think you
know a lot of people celebrated her
being you know censured you know by the
house recently I don't think that goes
far enough in that interview you know
one thing that hasn't been talked about
is that she said uh something about her
residence and she was talking about
Palestine last time I checked members of
Congress should be supporting the
American people the American interest
and that includes maybe and that's an
answer to your question about why she
hasn't called for the release of these
hostages because she's is more concerned
about representing Palestinians and not
the American people or even the people
in her District which isn't in the most
tiptop shape either yeah by the way
that's a really great point you know
earlier in the week during that censor
uh thing that Congress We we played the
clips of her and ilhan Omar and Cory
Bush and some of the others and you've
never ever seen any of them nearly as
passionate about what's going on in
their own districts you think Dearborn
Michigan might have some problems right
now do you do you think maybe she should
be focusing on that but of course that
but I want to shift to something else
because it's very easy for us obviously
to make fun of MSNBC and to make fun of
the Hamas caucus and everything else but
I'm also noticing another problem in the
in the online pundit class of a series
of people who seemingly talk as if they
know everything but really don't know
anything related to the history so I
want to show you a clip from Candace
Owens podcast personally look I do not
want to make this about Candice
specifically but Ian you you clipped
this and it went viral and I think
people were sort of catching on to
something that is a wider problem so
personally I'm not making this about
Candice uh but but take a look at the at
the confusion here when people call it
you know this Bastion of Freedom or it's
just like America I that's not the sense
that I have when I was there and again
we had talked earlier on about how our
own experiences obviously color our
opinions and I grew up you know my
grandparents house my grandfather grew
up in a segregated South and so when I'm
walking through Jerusalem and you see
and they say these are the Muslim
quarters this is where the Muslims are
allowed to live that doesn't feel like a
Bastion freedom to me um so I guess oh I
don't think it's where they're allowed
to live in Jerusalem I think it's that
there are there's an Armenian quarter
it's not saying the Armenians can only
live here it's that there are
communities just like there's a a Jewish
community in in Jersey here and there's
a Muslim Community in here I don't think
you know to my understanding it's not
restrictions within Israel proper where
isra where they I think it is where they
have I mean at least that's with the
rabbi who was taking me around he said
these are the Muslim quarters so this is
where the
Muslims live but I he didn't say
anything about legally saying they
cannot live on other places within
Israel proper I mean there's Israeli
Arab citizens that have full rights
Israeli Arab I'm talking about Jerusalem
so I haven't I haven't been to Tel Aviv
or anything like that I'm just talking
about particularly Jerusalem itself as a
city is has has a division in it where
the green line divides and there's East
Jerusalem that's maybe what he was
talking about not the Muslim quarter but
east Jerusalem um there's disputed
territory within the West Bank and East
Jerusalem that divides and therefore
they're under Palestinian Authority or
even other jurisdiction but I'm you know
that's that's that's a different
conversation as far as what those are
but Arabs within Israel if you go to
Israel people would be surprised to see
on every street sign Hebrew English and
Arabic you see a multicultural City so
I'm keep going a little bit because I'm
curious in your experience in Jus yeah I
know and maybe I'm misunderstanding it
but I think it's worth talking because I
I my understanding from the rabbi was
that this is where the Muslims have to
live in Jerusalem and it looked very
different from where you know the Jewish
people were living and that again that
could not be any fault of any person
other than this is how they take take
care of their stuff and this is the way
that we take care of their stuff but you
know it was noticeably a lot dirtier it
was noticeably a lot darker um and it
just made me feel as a black American
and knowing my own history that this is
not this isn't freedom to me like if you
can't just decide like I want to but I
want to live on that street or I want to
live on this straight but maybe I'm
maybe I'm wrong and it wasn't they were
just all might Mis this might have been
a misunderstanding imagine if you went
into an inner city in the United States
and somebody told you this a
predominantly black neighborhood and you
said it looked more rundown would you
say that America's systemically racist
because I was get a tour of it I
wouldn't say this is the black quarters
probably or this a black neighborhood
but maybe somebody in the group might
misunder understand that yeah you know
maybe I did yeah I was want to ask you
about that okay so again I don't want to
make this specifically about her but it
should be noted that when they talk
about Jerusalem and we were just there
six months ago and I I actually I said
to my guys right before we started we we
took a lot of video there and we'll show
something on Monday that explains how
these quarters work Israel didn't create
the Muslim quarter in thew Jewish
quarter and the Armenian quarter and
everything else first off they largely
live in peace you can actually Jews
generally don't walk through the Muslim
quarter because you might get killed but
anyone can walk through the entrance in
in West Jerusalem but the point is these
these quarters have existed for
thousands of years it's Israel that has
opened up Jerusalem to be an
international City that everyone can
come to when Jordan controlled Jerusalem
before 1967 Jews couldn't pray at the
Western Wall so again I don't want to
make this about her but this General
sort of let's just say anything and
apply all of our western belie or
American beliefs or something to
everything
else I don't like it
CJ yeah you know I I went to Israel over
the summer spent 10 days there and I got
to say that it was one of the most eye
openening experiences of my life you
know for a long time I've heard Every
Lie uh that you can imagine about Israel
how it's in a partied State how it's you
know Force segregation all those things
and what I saw what I experienced you
know going through Tel Aviv going
through yafa going through Jerusalem all
these places is that you saw many people
of many different Faith backgrounds many
different nationalities ethnicities
coexisting and living amongst one
another you don't see the same in Gaza
you don't see the same uh you know in in
those other areas and those M Muslim
controlled areas you know to your point
and so I think that that's the thing
here about this entire conflict there
are many people speaking about this
issue who number one haven't even gone
to Israel so they're believing every
single thing that they see on Instagram
or Twitter about this or even worse
maybe Tik Tok at times and I think that
it would they would be greatly uh helped
by just actually going and seeing this
for themselves and realizing that Israel
is truly the most tolerant place in the
Middle East it just Bar None uh and if
you really do care about tolerance if
you care about progressivism and all
these things then you should side with
them and probably not the people that
throw gay people off the top of
buildings that just a little bit of of
advice there Ian since you were the one
that made this clip go viral what do you
think about sort of the general concept
of you know we've watched the mainstream
media the corporate press has absolutely
collapsed I think most people believe
that and don't trust them anymore
obviously there's a certain set that do
but what do we do about this other piece
where now everyone's going to all of
these other shows and I would include
myself in that to find out something
that's true and often it is uh these are
ideas that are promulgated by people
that simply just don't know what they're
talking about yeah I think that's a
problem with the general commentary
class on both sides is that we have a a
a really a business system in which you
just are paid to say things you're paid
to have thoughts um but it gets a little
sticky when we're talking about things
with very deep consequences like the
Deep levels of anti-Semitism we're
seeing exploding all over the world
based on really a conspiracy theory of
antisemitism and a conspiracy theory
about Israel and so for example
comparing um Jerusalem to the
segregation of Jim Crow era is simply
not true uh I'm not going to talk about
you know the motivations behind that
because you can't look inside someone's
heart but the fact is it's not true but
has very deep and dangerous consequences
because then people will continue to
compare modern day Israel to Jim Crow
South to Nazi Germany and that is the
exact propaganda that places like
organizations like Hamas and students
for justice in palestin and all these
other groups are pushing they're
comparing Israel to racist fascist
apartheid regimes because that is their
entire excuse for all of the violence
that they then commit against Jews and
so I think whenever you're talking about
any issue um especially if you're
claiming Authority uh this is something
I try and do all the time it's very
tempting just to to talk about things to
pontificate um but you've always got to
be checking yourself making sure do I
actually know this and I think it's fine
to ask questions um but there's so many
resources out there so many people you
can engage with prior to speaking
publicly and I think it's uh really
everyone's duty to do so especially when
we're talking about something that has
deadly consequences because we are
seeing deadly consequences we're seeing
Jews being attacked on American streets
we're seeing um Israeli restaurants
Jewish restaurants being being attacked
simply for having a um a star of David
on the sign or an Israel flag outside
like these are very serious outcomes and
we need to be taking it seriously as a
result yeah it's kind of like how yeah
it's kind of how like after you know the
Ukraine war everyone was all of a sudden
the Soviet uh military historian and and
I'm not going to sit here and pretend
like I know every single cultural
implication about what's going on in the
region but what I do know is that I am
America first I know that we have you
know tens of thousands of homeless
veterans on our streets in America I
know that in many inner cities across
the country you have kids who aren't
proficient in either reading or math in
several several schools and I think that
we have a lot of problems here at home
and that is what kind of guides my
stance um on Ukraine but I think there
is so many people who just reflexively
just feel the need to weigh in on every
single issue without actually taking the
time to really bolster up their
knowledge um surrounding it you know but
to your point that you made I think it
was it was incredible um you know pal
you know the Palestinians and you know
the Hamas have been very very
intentional about trying to tie what
they're doing to the experiences of
black Americans and I'm working on an
opet about this right now black lives
matter black livs do not matter to Hamas
not in any way whatsoever when these
people chant death to America I hope the
black people who are saying oh I'm Pro
Palestine realize that we are also
Americans like they want to come for us
too and so at the end of the day it's
just so nonsensical because to your
point yes there are Muslim quarters
there are Arab quarters in Jerusalem but
there are black neighborhoods there are
white neighborhoods there are Hispanic
neighborhoods is anyone going to argue
that Little Havana in Miami is a Cuban
quarter no people self-segregate people
live around um you people you're not
going to believe what's going on in
Chinatown in New York
City yeah all right all right all right
let's I think we I think we made the
point uh let's move on because I wanted
to hit something that that's a little
bit different uh in terms of just sort
of the chaos of the last month but I
thought also in sort of opens the door
to a lot of the internet craziness we're
dealing with and how when even good
people try to do good things there is
always a price to pay so this guy Mr
Beast uh who is Hu he might be the is he
the number one YouTuber at this point he
is the number one YouTuber the guy's
worth a gajillion dollars and he takes
his gajillion dollars and he sees he
tries to do a lot of good things with
his money so one thing that he was
trying to do uh or that he not only not
was just trying to do that he actually
did was build aund
wells in Africa so that African children
could get fresh water you might think
that this is pretty good here's a little
bit of the video uh when he uh when he
did this and then put it up this about a
week ago 100 Wells we're going to build
in this
video
water oh crap you just witnessed a small
village in Kenya get access to unlimited
clean drinking water in less than a
second one down 99 N More wells in
Africa to go you're going to love this
video combined these 100 Wells are going
to give around half a million people
freshw to drink and after building some
more Wells on this side of Kenya we flew
South to the school system of niri and
let's just say they were really happy to
see us how's it going one of the
teachers showed me where the students
currently get their water which is from
this River that's extremely unsafe to
drink this where your students used to
get water from yes this is crazy at
least for this Village we're going to
put it into it right now I don't think
this John's going to
fit a big let's see if we can find some
water it is raining it's
beautiful okay so obviously it goes on
I'm being told this guy has 209 million
subscribers I have never felt so
irrelevant in my life but he's doing
doing good work he obviously has earned
them and earned all the accolades and
the financial success and everything
else but anyway so he does this thing
and uh and of course there was going to
be Fallout so first let's look at his
original tweet on this thing he
said we built a 100 wells in Africa go
watch and then Ashley stclair who I've
had on the show Ashley said waiting for
someone to call this racist and then on
Q here's Yahoo news while American
YouTuber Mr BEAST's goal was to provide
clean drinking water for 500,000 people
activists say his actions shamed the
Kenyon government and helped perpetuate
The Stereotype that Africa is dependent
on
handouts uh this eventually got hit with
a community note because this is now the
factchecking apparatus that uh you that
Twitter has uh brought in since Elon
took over readers added context they
thought might you might want to know
this is relative to the headline I just
read the two people deriding Mr Beast
are one a Kenyan politician and two a
woman who founded a 501c3 based in
Cambridge Massachusetts that raised
131,000 in 2020 and spent 83,000 on
themselves so all right this happens
with everything good people try to do
good things obviously the Kenyan
government is not doing everything they
can to get their own people clean water
he comes in and does it a canyon
government official is pissed because it
exposes him for being a fraud and these
nonprofit people that basically do not
also are not happy because it shows that
they don't do much of anything Ian this
is just Internet 101 right yeah yeah
everything is racist especially good
things I mean I cannot believe we can
watch people who don't have access to
clean water getting clean water
presumably for free you know they're not
paying for this and people are upset
about that I can't believe we're talking
about this right now of all the
horrendous things that happen in the
world people are angry because a guy
decided to go to Africa and get water
for people it's unbelievable I do think
it's funny when politicians and um
people in America nonprofits get very
upset when someone just completely
supersedes them and actually goes and
does the thing they've been promising to
do uh politicians are notoriously inept
and the same is true for a lot of
nonprofits out there quite often it's
just a way to get tax-free money if you
look at the salaries they pay themselves
you look at where the money goes so many
Charities have these kind of problems
and so it's obviously humiliating when
someone who has a YouTube show and
YouTube is still looked down upon by
many people who are still in the
mainstream even though it's where most
people go to get content nowadays when
he can just go to Africa and do it it it
shames them they should be embarrassed
uh but the fact that this is viewed as
racist like it's racist if you don't
provide people with water we're seeing
that in Gaza right now it's racist
people don't have water but it's racist
if you give them water I'm starting to
think that everything is racist Dave I
don't know if I'm wrong CJ um according
to my paperwork here you are
black I I think so well according to Joe
Biden no but that's neither here nor
there I think what's crazy about this
entire story here is that the people
that are complaining you have the Kon
politician obviously is just embarrassed
and you have a woman who lives in
Cambridge Massachusetts who for the
record anyone who's been there that's
the home of Harvard University not
necessarily a blue collar neighborhood
there but you know who isn't complaining
the Kenyan children who now have access
to fresh water like this is actually the
most insane story again like I I I agree
I can't believe that we are even talking
about this or have to talk about this
but this always happens he goes out he
does good and then people accuse him of
being of of over like abusing is
privilege so helping people in need is
abusing isn't that what they want isn't
this like some form of reparation like
it's insanity and as you said though
like no good deed goes un punnished
these days yeah and just to re iterate
the only reason I'm covering it is
because I want to expose that sort of
nonsense so less people fall for it next
time the next time they read that Mr
Beast is a racist or CJ is a white
supremacist or something like that Ian
I'll give you the last word on this one
and then we'll move on but also what
would happen if someone like Joe Biden
announced a scheme or Camala Harris was
going to be the water Zar she was going
to be sent down to Kenya people would be
celebrating her as a hero doesn't matter
if they deliver or not someone actually
delivers they're the villain the world
is upside down speaking of up the waters
are you get ready to go thirsty yeah
yeah we'd be dehydrated overnight uh all
right let's move on though because uh
speaking of upside down Neil degrass
Tyson who once I think was like a fairly
decent science Communicator before
wokeness just took over everything uh he
was sort of The Heir Apparent to Carl
Sean who's one of my heroes uh like who
was just such a had such an incredible
ability to explain complex things about
the cosmos to the masses he would go on
Johnny Carson Tonight Show all the time
and explain like unbelievable
astrophysics to people in a very decent
way that they could deal with while they
were going to sleep at 11:30 p.m. anyway
Neil deg Tyson was supposed to be him
number two and he's devolved into some
sort of like half woke very confused
person uh here he is on the Wild Ride
podcast explaining a bit more we played
One Clip earlier in the week when he was
on with Bill Mah but he's very confused
about all this gender stuff and well
look at how he's now dealing with his
shows if it's wrong to say ladies and
gentlemen yeah I don't say that anymore
for example in my public talks wow but
when they introduce me I say just say
humanoids because why specify gender at
all you just all humans who are out
there so say yeah so when I'm introduced
they have explicit instructions to say
instead of ladies and gentlemen which
has a ring to it right a historical sort
of Legacy feel to it it's just please
welcome to the stage Neil degrass Tyson
and anyone who hears that is going to be
human and react and so why specify I
like that man I think that I'm done
saying ladies and gentlemen you want to
give this one another shot no I think
that was fantastic you just retired
ladies and gent yeah yeah I mean ladies
and gentlemen that that is a load of
bunk uh let's be clear nobody's offended
by ladies and Gentlemen even if they
were it's completely ridiculous and we
don't always have to go to the lowest
common denominator again this is sort of
like the previous clip it's not that
it's the biggest thing in the world but
I think that these are like these little
markers in society where we just keep
catering to the crazy class whether it's
the media class who lies about people
doing good things like Mr Beast or the
people that are supposed to be our
intellects who our intellectuals who are
just constantly degrading everything
thing uh Ian ladies and gentlemen
offensive not offensive can you tell me
offensive so I guess so but I think
what's what's scariest for me is the
people of science are the ones diving
head first into this it's one thing to
have you know weirdo academics on
college campuses screaming various
things about gender but when supposed
Authorities on science and biology is
part of science you know the idea that
there is sex and it is different as part
of science when these people are diving
head first that's really scary it's like
mathematicians out there it's like
Steven Hawking announcing that 2 plus 2
is five that's the same kind of level of
what we're talking here it shows how
really Insidious gender theory has
become and you've got so many people
like Neil degrass Tyson who would really
care more about their popularity and
more their attention than basic truth
and so they'll quite happily throw
science their supposed love into the
shredder just to protect their own skin
I think that's really showing how
powerful gender theory has become CJ I
have a theory that young people actually
want older people to tell them the truth
they actually don't want this pandering
nonsense anymore I think it explains a
lot of Jordan Peterson's success and
many other people that they can't make
sense of the world because the people
before them that are supposed to hand
them something have decided to shred it
up does does that resonate with you yeah
I think it's definitely true and once
people realize that they've been lied to
for a long time that turns into anger
because who wants to be lied to and I
think what's really interesting to see
here which is why I talk to you know
oftentimes I get conservative parents
who will reach out to me on Instagram or
Twitter and they say you know how can I
prepare my kid to go to college I'm like
well it's biblical right you got to
train up your child in the way in which
they should go so when they're old they
won't depart from it the problem that we
have sometimes as conservatives is that
we're so worried about liberal
indoctrination that we kind of are like
oh let's not indoctrinate our kids
ourselves before they go to college and
it's like okay you don't have to
indoctrinate them but give them a
foundation so when they go to their
college campus and they listen to their
leftist Professor trying to cancel
ladies and gentlemen and say that there
are 100 genders or that gender is a
social construct they can rely back on
those teachings that you gave them as a
child and say this isn't correct this
isn't truthful this is wrong and that
they will have the courage and
conviction to sit there and raise their
hand and say I disagree because courage
is contagious you know there are often
times when I was at you know in school
and I went to the University of Alabama
which isn't definitely not as
Progressive as you know a UC Berkeley
but sometimes I would be the only person
in the class who would raise my hand and
say that's just not correct that's your
emotion you're trying to pass it off as
truth let's leave this alone um but you
know particularly in this clip I think
Ian hit it on the head it's it's
particularly troubling when you have
people of science you know pushing these
fars of an idea but also too remember
when a PhD like used to be a flex like
he would respect people who had them
because they were like intellectual
people now it's like the last people
that I ever want to speak to it's like
these people are so just drunk off of
their own so-called intellect and and
and just just Cosmopolitan you know
ambition to just cater to every single
crazy phenomenon these days that they've
lost their intellectual integrity and
it's uh it's sad because as you said you
know Neil degrass Eon I assume pretty
smart guy um you watch that clip and you
have doubts about that though and it's
not just the intellectuals who've lost
their credit which obviously is true I
would say anyone who's gone to college
at this point we just hired a new editor
this week and I was thrilled when I
found out he was a College Dropout I was
like bonus man Joey welcome aboard uh CJ
I just want to ask you one other thing
because you mentioned when you were in
college and speaking up against the
aggressive group think because you
happen to be black I'm guessing they
didn't treat you that well they kind of
took that card away if you spoke up
against uh it kind of doubles down on
the hate against you right yeah you know
it was interesting thankfully I had you
know a really supportive you know canas
community and and I think it was really
proof of what you just said young people
are tired of being lied to by the
progressives uh you know by these people
who are so hellbent on being woke that
they are willing to eliminate women out
of our society they're willing to
criminalize being white in America there
are lots of students at the University
of Alabama who were standing up against
that my professors however sometimes
weren't the biggest fan um of me they
were people who you know condemned me
for you know being prot Trump and you
know during the election and all of
these things but at the end of the day I
think that if you're not getting pushed
back that you're not pushing hard enough
and I think that America's young people
should know there are far more people
that agree with us than don't we just
got to be vocal and we've go to we've
got to get over this silent majority
nonsense being silent is permissive and
if we allow these people to continue to
wage a war on every single that we have
as a country they will win and so to
your point that's why we should talk
about things like this these stories
because it's kind of a little bit of a
dry run they test these crazy theories
these crazy ideas to see oh will anyone
push back will anyone is this too far
and and it makes me reminds me of uh
Jazz Jennings her TLC show no one was
talking about it at that point when you
know she was a kid undergoing gender
transition people kind of looked at it
as like a human interest story like
people weren't really vocal about how
bad it was I think it was around like I
was a little kid um but now we're seeing
it Go mainstream and people are like oh
my God this is so bad well maybe if we
had condemned it back then we wouldn't
be where we are now so I think it's
really important to nip these things in
the bud before they grow into even a
bigger phenomenon than they already are
yeah well said and you gave me a great
segue because speaking of nipping things
in the bud you know for years a whole
bunch of us were saying that they're
calling all of the wrong people Nazis
and the people that are doing it tend to
have some Nazi Tendencies and we're
certainly seeing that on the streets of
all of many of our cities unfortunately
and all over Europe and everywhere else
uh but Hillary Clinton and you'll see my
connection here Hillary Clinton went on
The View this week and you're not going
to believe who she compared Donald Trump
to people would get legitimately
elected and then they would try to do
away with elections and do away with
opposition and do away with a free press
and you could see it in countries where
well Hitler was duly elected right right
and so all of a sudden somebody with
those Tendencies though dictatorial
authoritarian Tendencies would be like
okay we're going to shut this down we're
going to throw these people in jail and
and they didn't usually Telegraph that
Trump is telling us what He intends to
do how about what Trump did uh because
he did not do away with the Free Press
he fought a free press all the time uh
he did not do away with elections he's
not the president as as far as I know
Ian this this insanity this it's so damn
unfortunate because now when we have
people behaving like the Nazis going
after Jewish shops as you mentioned and
all of the other stuff uh the words
don't even have any meaning anymore yeah
I mean like two things one zalinski is
actually doing all of these things and
she's presumably still a massive fan of
Ukraine so I'm not to uh too sure she
actually cares about fascism or any of
these things but also if you just look
at the Nazi analogy as we've talked
about know during this show there are
actual Nazis on the streets right now
screaming for the same thing that Nazis
wanted outside the Sydney Opera House
for example people were literally
screaming gas the Jews you see Pro
Palestinian people holding up swastikas
um painting swastikas on Jewish students
doors like Nazis are here they just
don't happen to be uh White in this case
and they don't happen to be um part of
the political narrative that people like
Hillary Clinton want to push and so it
doesn't count uh and also if you look at
really the safety of Jews if that's
going to be the metric we use to measure
the level of Nazism in the the world
then the world was a much safer Jew
place for Jews under Donald Trump than
it was under Barack Obama and certainly
under Joe Biden so the the Hitler
analogy is obviously stupid but it's
incredibly dangerous when we have people
who are on the streets right now
cheering for Hitler it's just
unbelievable CJ is this the great trick
that Democrats do all the time it's like
we all see what's happening on the
streets we hear the chance everything
that Ian just referenced right there but
then they can get someone like Hillary
to go on mainstream media and then say
Hitler in a way that for all the
Liberals who are breaking right now and
and we we know it's happening right now
a lot of Liberals are kind of waking up
right now they suddenly hear that and
then they immediately go back the wrong
way because of that very tactic you're
exactly right you know the same uh you
know Playbook that they run you know
towards Jewish Americans the same
Playbook they've always ran towards
black Americans they compare every
single conservative to a white
supremacist to a Clansman to uh you know
some terrible terrible you know white
supremacists or Nazi and it's it's the
only thing that they know how to do they
the only thing that they know the only
way they know how to win is by pitting
white people against black people Jews
against you know everyone else and that
because identity politics is all they
have to run on they can't run on the
economy they can't run on education they
can't run on Public Safety so they run
on this just absolute just demagogy
which is absolutely disgusting and yeah
Ian's point I thought she was talking
about zalinsky for that entire little
thing until she set Donald Trump at the
end considering he is literally now
saying that there shouldn't be an
election he also Consolidated all of the
media into one state run media entity
everything that she just said is
literally what zalinski is doing but of
course no criticism of him from her I
wouldn't expect that um but again to
your point all these anti-semitic
attacks that we're seeing in the country
right now are not being waged by people
wearing Maga hats no what we're seeing
are people who are big supporters of
folks like former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton big supporters um of
progressive politicians like Rashida
Talib Alan Omar these are people who are
not trying to conceal who they are in
any which way they are calling for the
extermination of the Jewish people they
are chanting from The River To The Sea
they are siding with Hamas and it's so
crazy to kind of say that out loud
sometimes because it's like oh because
it's one thing to side with Democrats
it's one thing to side with Republicans
siding with Hamas should have some
weight to it when you say it because
they are literal terrorists imagine if a
few years ago we were going around
saying that people were siding with Isis
those people would be ex communicated
from society for very good reason it is
not it's just not a moral sance to have
in any which way yeah basically clean up
the Nazis in your own party Hillary and
then we'll deal with your other
imaginary Nazis uh guys let's do this
again this was a good Duo I appreciate
it have a great weekend we'll link to
all your stuff down below and in about
27 seconds we will have a postgame show
at Ruben report. locals.com thanks
everybody have a great weekend we need
to penetrate them
blow our loads and then subsequently
pull out as needed I actually prefer if
we stay inside for an extended period of
time because we need to make sure that
the deed is done uh I have been an
expert on this subject for many years
and I think now is the time to
[Music]
act